♪ ♪
[humming]
Doink.
♪ ♪
I'll put one there.
Doink.
[hums]
Ooh, that's good.
And finally,
I'll put one--
Can I help you?
Oh, you startled me, I--
You got five seconds, or I paint
this kitchen with your brains.
Okay, okay,
don't shoot, please don't.
I'm sorry,
I'm-I'm the Easter Bunny!
The what now?
The Easter Bunny.
The...okay.
And just what in the hell
do you think you're doing
in my house...Easter Bunny?
Duh! I'm just hiding eggs,
you know, for your kids,
for your children.
Eggs? For my kids?
Well, not real eggs.
Plastic eggs.
And they're filled
with candy.
- Candy?
- Yeah, candy.
I just wanna give
your kids candy.
Whoa, okay! Sir, I--
Let me get this straight.
You break into my house
in the middle of the night
in a goddamn rabbit costume...
I'm not a costume.
To give my children candy?
Not give. Hide.
They have to find it
to eat it, but--
You child-molesting
mother[bleep]!
What? No, no! No, no!
You got ten seconds to get out
of here, or I start firing. One.
Okay. All right.
I'm leaving. I'm walking away.
Two.
But just so you know,
sir, I--
Ten.
[gunshot]
My face.
And that's how you know
the Easter Bunny isn't real.
Well...
[yawns]
Now it's time
to get some sleep.
Mwah.
Good night, my sweet,
sweet boys.
Mwah.
And just so you know,
I love you.
[kisses]
[chuckles]
Why was that man
wearing Dad's robe?
I'm scared.